the synergy between character classes is
one of the things that makes the battle
against hordes of xenomorphs exciting in
aliens fire team elite with the start of
the game's first live content season
developer cold iron is adding a new
brand of marine to the battlefield the
phalanx class we got a chance to go
hands-on with the phanlance ahead of its
release to see what it adds to your
fireteam if you like this video and you
want to see more coverage of aliens
fireteam elite go ahead and hit the like
and subscribe buttons
as the name suggests the phalanx marine
sports a deployable shield that turns it
into a frontline fighter acting as your
team's tank the shield can block melee
damage and incoming shots allowing you
to better survive some close encounters
with both alien enemies and the
synthetic soldiers that populate the
campaign it's a trooper that's great for
drawing fire and drawing a crowd so the
rest of your three-player squad can
avoid being overwhelmed and pick off
enemies with a little more space to
breathe the phalanx's primary ability is
a shield you can toggle on or off
there's no cooldown on this thing when
you pull the shield out it allows you to
absorb attacks without getting hurt so
long as they're coming from in front of
you that incentivizes you to hold down
choke points and wade into narrow
corridors attacks from the side or
behind acid damage and some explosions
will still hurt but for the most part if
you can funnel your attackers into a
place where you can only fight them head
on you can block their attacks and blow
them apart with a shotgun your passive
ability bulwark increases the damage
your weapons do for every attack you
block with your shield so there's a big
incentive to try to keep it deployed as
much as possible
using the phalanx shield can be pretty
effective but it comes with drawbacks
first you can only use handguns and
close quarters weapons with this class
since you only have one hand to operate
your guns you can use them from behind
your shield but you lose the ability to
move quickly while the shield is
deployed that can make it tough to
respond to threats coming at you from
the sides or behind but sprinting or
dodging automatically folds the shield
up making it possible to quickly escape
when something like a xenomorph warrior
comes roaring at you
controlling crowds and keeping enemy
attention is the phalanx is back and
your second ability is the shock pulse
it stuns enemies in a radius around you
making it great for those moments when
you're unexpectedly surrounded and your
shield isn't helping the shock pulse
also dishes out damage over time and can
be tweaked to either hit enemies harder
with that initial blast or stun them
more effectively coupled with the shield
the ability is great for allowing you to
walk into danger and take lots of
enemies out of the fight at once so you
and your team can mop them up before
they become a problem aliens fire team
elite works to toe the line between
making you feel like a badass but one
who knows that the situation you're
fighting through could go badly at any
second having the shield is great but it
won't stop everything coming at you you
can block some but probably not all
explosive damage with the shield and it
won't keep acid from messing up your
feet should you walk through some it
also won't protect you from enemies that
grab you like the warrior or the prowler
you still need to keep your head on a
swivel and when things get rough you'll
sometimes need to stow the shield and
get out of harm's way just like the
other classes do as with all the classes
in aliens fireteam elite the phan links
is best used in conjunction with a
diverse fire team backing you up its
ability to tank damage and zap several
enemies at once are great when paired
with the dock class which can throw down
a trauma station to keep the phalanx
healed to absorb even more punishment a
high damage class like the demolisher or
gunner is a good addition for killing
enemies quickly to make sure the phalanx
doesn't become overwhelmed as the
phalanx we found it was very easy to
find yourself thinking you're in better
shape than you are and to be so focused
on dealing with one set of enemies that
you forget about another set coming up
on your flank the phalanx class is free
to all aliens fire team elite players
and is part of the game's first content
season which kicks off on september 8th
the season also includes several new
weapons you can earn in-game including a
laser pistol modeled after weapons seen
in the original alien and a new assault
rifle minigun and sniper rifle if you
want to see more of what i'm talking
about here's gameplay of the phalanx in
action as we take on xenomorphs and the
weyland yutani synthetics in alien fire
team elites second campaign giants in
the earth
ain't over till it's over they get sit
tight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
approach
must have heard the gunfire
should not be capable of this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
shut down
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
is
the computers here are protected by 16
million character ciphers
esther seal the door behind them catch
your breath fire team rodriguez is just
ahead